wir waren ja zum teil der ohnehin schon
mittendrin weil kanzel culture in der
mitte der gesellschaft angekommen und
wenn man so will also nicht nur wie man
früher gesagt hat ein phänomen an den
amerikanischen ostküsten universitäten
werden welche schneeflocken ihre safe
spaces und trigger warnings haben wollen
weil sie jeden vorlesungssäle nichts
mehr hören wollen was ihnen nicht
gefällt sozusagen sondern es ist ja in
der breiten öffentlichen debatte in
westeuropa auch in deutschland noch
nicht ganz so sehr in österreich ist
halt kleiner angekommen dass
letztendlich menschen die eine meinung
vertreten die möglicherweise vom
mainstream in der gesellschaft abweicht
oder von sehr einflussreichen und
mächtigen lobbygruppen nicht geteilt
wird dass es gelingt die so weit an den
rand zu drängen dass man auch die leute
die medienöffentlichkeit zur verfügung
stellen so weit bringt sie das
eigentlich weglassen also dass die
talkshows menschen die solche positionen
vertreten nicht mehr einladen dass ich
sie einladen aber dann vier andere die
abgesprochene weise die platt machen
oder das machen will dann die medien
plattformen wie das machen bedroht dass
man wirtschaftlich schade dass man sich
nicht beteiligen ich glaube das haus
hier hat dass wir auch hautnah miterlebt
wie das so ist wenn man nur einen
gastkommentar
fertigt der dessen meinung nicht sein
dass man sie wirklich fragt bitte warum
sollte sowas nicht mehr scheines durch
weit innerhalb jedes meinungs- korridors
thema zu dem thema haben kann warum
sollte das nicht stattfinden die leute
haben offensichtlich nicht verstanden
dass sie möglicherweise das sie selber
denken ohnehin schon wissen und
vielleicht sagen ihr weltbild nur
erweitern können wenn so etwas lesen
sehen hören was sie nicht schon selber
denken wir haben das während der zwei
jahren der pandemie erlebt dass menschen
die irgendwie mit
wir reden jetzt nicht von leuten ist das
virus gibt es gar nicht und die impfung
wird uns alle töten
sondern von menschen die sagen okay wir
haben da eine situation die war neu ist
es jetzt angemessen einerseits
medizinisch andererseits aber auch
freiheits rechtlich und in der
perspektive der verfassungsmäßig
garantierten freiheits und bürgerrechte
diese oder jene maßnahmen zu treffen zu
treffen wer sich der kritisch geäußert
wurde wurde automatisch in eine ecke
trinkwasser das ist glaube ich dann
begriffen sind leute die irgendwie
wissenschaft nicht folgen also das hat
sich irgendwie total verstärkt natürlich
innerhalb dieser zwei jahre pandemie wir
merken es aber jetzt natürlich auch in
der ukraine krieg wenn jemand sagt es
ist ja doch eigentlich wichtiger zu
verhandeln das zu helfen muss man nicht
teilen eigentlich persönlich auch nicht
ich glaube nicht dass man einen krieg
durch reden beenden kann aber das ist
doch eine position die man hören muss
sind der gesellschaft da ist ich glaube
auch in deutschland zu einem gar nicht
so geringen ausmaß es hat auch keinen
sinn positionen die da sind auch in
einer gesellschaft relativ weit
verbreitet da sehen wir zu ignorieren
indem er ihre repräsentanten auf
öffentlichen medien plattformen
cancelled verstummt und weg schaltet das
hat zwei dinge glaube ich das eine ist
dass es darum geht so was wie eine
lufthoheit über den stammtischen
irgendwie herzustellen das ist eine eine
frage der macht den gesellschaftlichen
diskurs es wird doch dann schon auch
immer öfter dazu verwendet und
konkurrenten irgendwie auszuschalten wir
sehen uns wirtschaftliche den eindruck
habe ich auch und ich glaube wenn wir
dem nicht wirklich etwas entgegensetzen
dann werden wir in einer gesellschaft
landen in der stadt sächlich sowas wie
meinungsdiktatur gibt weil sich einfach
niemand mehr traut etwas anderes zu
sagen weil er dann seinen job und
universität verliert weil er nicht mehr
auftreten kann weil er seine
existenziellen grundlagen auch beruflich
verliert und ich glaube wir sind an der
situation näher dran also wird das immer
vorgestellt und sagen alle reha aber man
kann das ja eh sagen also frau geht zb
ich die in umfragen
war hier wurde dann irgendwie in der
talkshow von markus lanz irgendwie
abgestimmter weise filetiert und
irgendwie ausradiert und natürlich gibt
es parallelen bei der süddeutschen
zeitung zum beispiel morgen abend als
jetzt nicht gecancelt würde ich jetzt ja
ja aber ja genau das wird dann immer
gesagt man darf ja eh auftreten
parallele offen natürlich dann versuchen
sie zum beispiel von ihrem lehrstuhl an
der uni bonn zu entfernen das
gab es schon heute haben sie haben ihre
die haben ihre positionen ihre
akademischen positionen verloren weil
sie positionen vertreten die anderen
nicht passen und die möglicherweise
nicht im mainstream oder in der mehrheit
der gesellschaft liegen oft sind es
sogar positionen die wenn man dann
wirklich die gesellschaftliche
stimmungslage ab fragen würde sogar
mehrheitsfähig sind aber in einer
gewissen blase die hat meinungs-
dominieren die es nicht mehrheitsfähig
sind und dieses ungleichgewicht und
diese asymmetrie zwischen einen
mächtigen blasen die meinung dominieren
können und dem rest der gesellschaft das
macht eine trifft auf von der ich glaube
dass sie eine ende tatsächlich
demokratie gefährden sehen sie das auch
so ja leider so also gerade das kona
beispiel irgendwann als sehr sehr gut
ist das wenn man privat mit leuten
spricht ein ganz anderes meinungsbild
bekommt als wenn man dann das ja in den
medien hört und mittlerweile fast
wirklich wie eine diktatur ein
bestimmter weg vorgegeben wird und fast
wenn man ein bisserl abweicht
entsprechend dann schon mehr
abgestempelt wird und dann leider auch
sofort immer an den rechten oder linken
rand geschoben wird dieses
meinungsvielfalt in dem fall fähig sehr
schade fällt weg und auch hier gibt ihn
absolut recht
nur verhandlungen oder sprechen wir
nicht funktionieren aber jeglicher 1
kommentar wenn man sagt man müsste sich
das genauer angucken dieses thema was
vorher passiert worden ist ja ein paar
stimmen die das sind auch sagen woher
das alles resultiert noch mal ganz
schlimm was passiert muss verändert
werden bin ich absolut der meinung aber
sich trotzdem diesem thema mal anziehen
konnten geht man sofort kenterte um
gottes willen das darf sie nicht und das
thema ist tabu und von daher bin ich auf
jeden fall auch der mann dass man da
viel breiter mehr meinung zu lassen
sollte und eine diskussion auch in den
medien erlaubt soll darf ich eine
ergänzung vielleicht machen weil es noch
älter ist als die pandemie wesentliches
mittel dazu ist er eigentlich die
pathologisierung von anders meinen das
hat begonnen in der ganzen diskussion
nach 2015 wenn man sozusagen kritisch
sich gegenüber aktuellen
erscheinungsformen des politischen islam
weltweit dieses dominant geäußert hat
dann wurde man und das wurde sogar
herausgegeben von der columbia
university in new york unter der ägide
eines österreichischen
forschers muss ich wirklich sagen unter
anführungszeichen dann ist das das
islamophobie handbuch das heißt wenn
jemand zu einer gewissen sache in dem
fall zum zugpferd derzeit in
erscheinungsform des politischen islam
weltweit kritisch ist dann wird er
eigentlich pathologisiert sagt er hat
eine phobie eigentlich eine psychische
krankheit
das war dann in der epidemie also in der
pandemie nicht anders wenn eine andere
meinung war zur bekämpfung der pandemie
dann wahre ein schwuler oder ein
wissenschaftler also auch jemand
ziemlich
zum beispiel ich war sehr stark in die
crawler maßnahmen ich war wahrscheinlich
ich würde sagen eine der lautesten
stimmen die dagegen war ich wurde weder
bei meinem arbeitgeber noch in meinem
umfeld als schwuler abgetan das habe ich
zum beispiel nicht erlebt deswegen würde
ich einmal die frage oder hier weiter
öffnen ob zum beispiel du julian mit
gehst dass wir diese fehlende
meinungsfreiheit haben oder ob viele
menschen sich einfach selbst
zurücknehmen ihre meinung zu äußern ich
finde das ist ja noch mal eklatanter
unterschied also ich würde zwei sachen
auf eine einen seite sie hatten frau
genannt ich kann hier noch nennen herrn
erich fahrt habe ich vorhin schon
genannt herr fahrweg frau sahra
wagenknecht die alle die meinung
vertreten alle seiten aber auf genau die
wir sollten wir sollten aufhören und
will ganze dorf beziehen aber ich würde
sagen die haben alle die meinung dass
das was wir keine weiteren waffen
liefern sollten und dass das ein problem
ist dass das mit einer
verhandlungslösung auch wenn putin
verhandeln möchte aber egal das dass man
mit verhandlungslösungen das ganze
erregen soll also die sind für mich
omnipräsent in allen talkshows zum thema
in allen talkshows wird ja
weiland zb wurde er wirklich ich muss es
richtig dass ich gesagt habe dass
eingedroschen wird das dass man dann dem
entgegen stellt aber ich hab jetzt
mindestens drei leute die das anders
sehen das ist tatsächlich ein problem
und das ist ja nichts neues ja das ist
ja wirklich seid ja seit jahren mit fast
einem jahrzehnt ist das so dass dass
gesagt wird ich bau diese talkshow so
auf das ist der star gehört so das ist
der schwache unterstützen und das ist ja
starke der genau anders man ist und noch
ein starker und am ende haben wir dann
dieses ergebnis und ich denke und das
sieht man jetzt nicht da zum ersten mal
also das sieht man auch wenn beim thema
natürlich corona und auf einer
flüchtlingskrise sie haben auch
angesprochen das fällt wenn man genau
hinguckt schon auf dass da eine gewisse
also historische sondern solche details
öffnung sonnenschein offenheit herrscht
aber am ende doch gesagt wird ja zur
unterstützung position haben diese
personen eingeladen am ende soll das so
aussehen und das ist tatsächlich großes
problem ja der iren selbst und schon im
haller
wir haben vielleicht mit enden wir
versuchen es dort eben anders zu machen
und das wird dann sehr oft mit der
kritik bedacht ist falls bällen sind
also man könne doch also in gegnerschaft
zum beispiel ist das beste beispiel es
gibt in österreich
immer vier prozent ins gegner wie kann
sein dass bei einer sendung über die
impfungen sinnhaftigkeit einer gewissen
impfung bei 4 sammelt was er einfach es
bei vier teilnehmern zwei kritische sind
und zwei befürworter das sei doch
absolut vorstellen sind man kann ja nun
zurückfahren kann ich dann jemanden der
das kritisch sieht erst einladen den 25
teilnehmer am tisch sitzen damit das
paritätisch irgendwie ausgeglichen ist
nein kann ich nicht falls balancing sind
begriffe aus dem
wissenschaftsjournalismus kommt wo ich
sagt wenn ich innerhalb einer
forschergemeinschaft eines eines
wirklich wissenschaftlichen internen des
kurses eine einzelmeinung genauso stark
bringe wie die meinung von 99 sagen
anerkannten wissenschaftlern dazu dann
dann gibt es eine eine falsche balance
vorstellen wenn ich das für
gesellschaftliche debatten um läge dann
würde ich sagen ist das für sich falls
bällen sind weil ich sie ist nicht die
aufgabe von einer medienplattform einer
öffentlichen debatte von öffentlichen
medien einen streng wissenschaftlichen
diskurs abzubilden sondern diskurse in
einer gesellschaft und der unterscheidet
sich inhaltlich und auch wenn man so
will die zahlenmäßig substanziell von
einem diskurs in einer abgeschirmten
engen wissenschaftlichen
umgebung und das scheinen die leute noch
nicht zu verstehen und diese übertragung
dieses begriffs vollends balancing
auffassung von einem ganz klar ein
gezirkelten wissenschaftlichen bereich
auf gesellschaftliche fragen ist eben
genau wieder nur ein versuch leute die
anderer meinung sind also müssen wir als
lösungsansatz weg davon
wissenschaftlichen ansätzen nein ich
glaube dass jeder seinen platz hat
wissenschaftliche diskussionen haben
ihre eigenen plattformen oder gips piano
dass die kann man dann irgendwie auch
referieren aber wir müssen einfach uns
klar machen dass man in einer
öffentlichen diskussion jede position
die es gibt in diesem öffentlichen
diskurs auch zeigen muss und wir weder
es sinnvoll ist noch wer das recht dazu
haben darüber zu entscheiden wer in
einer gesellschaft gehört werden darf
und wer nicht und jetzt mal einfach
wirklich weiter aufmachen stimmig
stimmlich sehr zu er von einer die sehen
sie denn die kennziffer sich schon ein
forensischer vor dem torschuss überhaupt
gar nichts ich habe ja bild live oder
hab die bild zeitung da wäre kam nach 15
uhr geht es los am computer bild zeitung
die informationen die information ist
gut kräftig da lebe ich danach das ist
doch ein super aufruf bild tv zuschauen
bild live will nach acht hier wird
niemand gecancelt wer von anhalt jetzt
gesagt hat das lob nehmen wir an